[Musique]
on appelle cette proposition de loi et
galine de en réalité elle s'appelle
comment améliorer la rémunération des
agriculteurs mais c'est vrai qu'elle
fait suite à la loi et galim 1 sur
laquelle le sénat n'avait pas émis un
avis favorable nous pensions que ça
n'aurait pas d'impact sur la
rémunération des agriculteurs en
particulier une disposition qui
s'appelle seuil de revente à perte plus
dix qui était un mécanisme qui était
censé ruisselé dans les cours de ferme
est en réalité qui n'a pas du tout
fonctionné
tout loi et galim 2 vient corriger un
certain nombre de choses nous étions
assez d'accord sur le principe de la
contractualisation de l'amont
c'est-à-dire la contractualisation des
producteurs et ensuite des
transformateurs pour permettre de
déterminer des coûts agricole qui soit
basée sur des coûts de production pas
seulement les sur des coûts de
production en revanche il y avait un
fort déséquilibre dans le texte sur la
deuxième partie c'est à dire sur la
partie des négociations entre les
transformateurs et les distributeurs
donc nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur
senna pour essayer de rééquilibrer en
réalité les relations entre
distributeurs et fabricants et également
pour élargir
le nombre de produits qui étaient
concernés pour les agriculteurs parce
que par exemple il n'ya on ne parlait
jamais des marques de distributeurs en
les marques des distributeurs c'est 30 %
du revenu des agriculteurs donc en
réalité quand la loi est arrivé ici ça
ne concernait que 20% du revenu des
agriculteurs
on était satisfait du travail qui a été
mené même si on n'a aucune illusion sur
la force et la rapidité de son effet sur
la rémunération des agriculteurs
on est satisfait parce qu'on pense qu'on
sort avec un texte qui est moins
déséquilibré pour les industriels de
l'agroalimentaire par rapport à la
grande distribution mais tant que nous
ne parlons pas du reste du revenu des
agriculteurs c'est à dire à la fois des
exportations des charges qui sont
grandissantes et qui sont supérieures à
celles d'autres pays européens tant
qu'on parle pas de la compétitivité de
notre agriculture
eh bien on a résolu qu'une toute petite
partie des sujets et puis les marchés à
l'école c'est des marchés internationaux
sur lequel il ya des prix de marchés
internationaux et évidemment c'est plus
haut à égalité 2 ne règle qu'une petite
partie du sujet puisque elle ne règle
évidemment elle ne régule évidemment peu
les transactions française